today marks the anniversary of beijing's
1989 tiananmen square massacre
commemorations are banned and social
media users are even reporting that the
candle emoji con
cannot be used today for several weeks
leading up to the june 4
1989 date the square had become a focal
point
for protests against the economic
hardship and corruption
students also gathered to demand
democratic rights and freedoms
from the communist government but by
june 4th
chinese leaders sent in troops to crush
the demonstrations
footage of a lone protester standing in
front of a line of tanks
has become one of the most enduring
symbols of the crackdown
no one knows exactly how many people
were killed on june 4th
1989 some say hundreds others
thousands
is one of the leaders of the student pro
democracy movement in china from 1989
and he joins
me now from taiwan where he currently
lives
welcome to the program and thank you so
much for joining us
you are a survivor of the massacre that
the chinese government seems to want to
erase from the memory of its citizens
how does that make you feel
well i'm a well so being a survivor
itself
you have to carry the guilt uh but then
also
the effect that i cannot commemorate uh
we cannot go back go to hong kong we
cannot go the hong kong people who have
been holding this
kendo vigil for many many years cannot
commemorate it also
shows the fragility of the
chinese communist regime it is a day of
commemoration for the
young who sacrificed their lives
prohibiting people from doing
just this commemoration
is is an inhumane
commemoration remembrance is one of the
most humble force of resistance
chinese communist regime also knows that
so there
the logic for the chinese communist
regime lays there they know
we want to remember and then that's the
that's the one thing
the communist party afraid the most
remembrance
absolutely um and take us back if you
will
um to those moments in the days of the
early summer of 1989 you were 21
back then what kind of change did you
want to see
well the political reform was promised
by chinese region by deng xiaoping to
chinese people
we were simply demanding they fulfill
their promises
but in china and even in 1989
10 years after the dung shopping era of
reopening reform
still it is a very very uh suppressed uh
regime a suppressed society taking the
street
uh of beijing is not an easy um
thing to do it's not uh they're they're
very
they're dangerous but i think the
students
in beijing across the city and then
across the country have demonstrated a
strong
uh determination that we want that
political reform
once we were promised and then their
response from the government at the
beginning was like police batons and
then
uh a fake dialogue that they they
struck a dialogue to uh uh to uh
uh uh to have the government organize
the student organizat
organizations members to have them so we
escalated
the movement into hunger strike we have
get the support
from all over the country all over the
world
but we could not move the emperor in who
lives in the
i mean we call themselves the general
secretary so uh they answered us at the
end
with bloodshed uh later known to the
world as
june 4th massacre absolutely and i mean
it was a massacre that shocked the world
indeed
and i'm wondering what what you're
thinking was back then i mean did you
suspect
you know as you were going through the
hunger strikes as you were demonstrating
that the chinese government would indeed
crack down so hard and send in tanks and
literally run down the protesters
we never thought that the chinese
government would
actually mobilize standing troops
against peaceful demonstrators
uh it's part of the par chinese
communist party's propaganda
is that they are the people's government
and then
the outstanding army people's liberation
army is people's army
it's unthinkable for any chinese citizen
in 1989 before the june 4th before the
night of june force
to imagine chinese regime open fire
to its own people
[Music]
so it certainly didn't occur to us we
thought okay yeah they're going to
suppress the movement
probably using the police baton and then
uh club us out of the square
uh using real ammunition and then roll
over
uh people protester on this on the
street
with uh you know um tanks and military
uh people movers and that is just
uh it shocked all of us i think you just
said it shocked the world yes
it also certainly shocked uh a billion
chinese
and you had to flee china we understand
after uh the 1989 massacre you you
haven't seen your family since
um when you reflect i mean
this commitment that you have was it
worth the decades of sacrifice that
followed
well uh if you if you ask me is it worth
it i don't know how to how to calculate
it but i can answer
you in a different angle that i don't
regret what i did
we didn't do anything wrong the price we
paid was hot or high
so high we don't know how to uh really
calculate uh
is it worth it but we also know
the what we did in tiananmen inspired
uh people to follow around the world
especially in york
in the country of in germany i mean it
basically leads to
the peaceful ending of the people's uh
uh demonstration in
at that time east germany and then
eventually lead to the uh renew a
falling of the berlin wall and the
reunification of germany
the impact of the 1989 student movement
is huge
to the world unfortunately just not
to china where kaichi we thank you so
much for joining us here on dw news one
of the leaders of the student
democracy movement in china in 1989
we appreciate it it's my pleasure
and as we've been hearing on this 32nd
anniversary police in hong kong have
arrested pro-democracy
activist chao hung-tung usually
she would be leading a mass vigil for
the victims of the tiananmen square
massacre but hong kong authorities
have banned the commemoration for a
second year in a row
dw correspondent phoebe kong met with
her recently
and her report was filmed before the
arrest
a warning shot to would-be protesters on
the anniversary of the day
the quash democracy activist ciao hang
tong
arrested by plainclothes police her
alleged crime
promoting unauthorized assembly
chao was one of the few leaders of hong
kong's pro-democracy movement
not already behind bars the arrest comes
a day after authorities threatened to
jail anyone attending the vigil
for up to five years
for over three decades the sea of
candlelight in hong kong
kept the events of 1989 alive the city's
annual vigil
a symbol of defiance unthinkable on
mainland china
but now even handing out candles is
heavily policed
weeks ahead of the 32nd anniversary the
organization hong kong alliance
led by chao began promoting the annual
commemoration
the first since beijing imposed a
national security law here
ciao at the time eerily pressured
people are even more supportive i would
say but the support is
less like expressive it's actually
gone beyond just the remembrance of
tamman it's also
go to the heart of what
hong kong is whether we still have to
fight
fighting our heart whether we are still
resisting where we can still
preserve our freedom by our own actions
also we'll share this faith with the
people who are already arrested and in
custody
but their hands are largely tied police
have manned the vigil for the second
year in a row
citing cobit's safety restrictions
although other mass gatherings like
concerts and soccer matches
have resumed
just two days before the anniversary the
alliance's june 4 museum
a museum commemorating the events of
1989
was closed down due to a licensing
investigation by the authorities
many of the organization's leading
members are in jail for protesting
including chairman lee chuck yan
we spoke to the veteran activist shortly
before he was sentenced to 18 months in
prison
we are in the darkness we are like in a
tunnel but if everyone still come up
with
a candle that is the spirit that we are
looking for
i believe in the people hong kong we
live in truth make sure
that the hong kong people know that we
never give up
even though maybe we have to go to jail
for the alliance it's not just about
commemorating the protests of 1989
but about being able to dissent to be
able to call for an end to one party
rule
but democracy protests are now labeled
as subversion by beijing
it could be a reason to outlaw the
activism and the alliance itself
we are not sell sending ourselves
there's no question that the government
wants to eradicate
the risk is not insisting on some slogan
or some
some principle the risk is what we are
doing
if you are sincerely fighting for the
end of one party dictatorship there will
always be that risk
there is cannot be avoided by just like
crossing out one of the slogans whether
this happens
sooner or later this happened a long way
away depends on how hard it
resists right workers at the alliance
june 4th museum have begun preserving
the [ __ ] square exhibits in digital
format
if china continues to close down all
avenues of physical protests in hong
kong
moving historical evidence to an online
museum may end up being one of the last
remaining ways
of showing resistance
and for more let's bring in dw hong kong
correspondent
phoebe kong who put that piece together
for us phoebe joins us now phoebe
the arrest of chao hong tang just walk
us through the significance of this move
and
what signal it sends to the
pro-democracy movement in hong kong
well the 37-year-old lawyer
is one of the prominent activists in
hong kong and also the core member of
the annual candlelight visual
organization hong kong alliances
mentioned in the report that she has
been engaging in
chinese human rights work and also local
activism
for long periods of time so her arrest
which is pretty high profile on these
sensitive dates on the anniversary of
the attainment crackdown which is
of like one of the most insensitive
political taboo in china
that uh her arrest actually is a warning
sent by the authorities
to the democracy camp and also the
general public in hong kong as a whole
that the authorities are not going to
tolerate
any kind of commemoration that not only
they are going to ban
the uh signature candlelight vigil but
also going after
individuals who want to sustain that
kind of commemoration and assistance
so um this is uh definitely a deterrent
on these sensitive days that
the authorities want to stand out all
kind of commemoration
or any kind of physical morning that
about this a
very um like uh the throne of
the communist party uh the chinese
ruling party
so the official ban is then in place
talk with us about the mood are people
still determined
to gather
well um the atmosphere on the ground is
really tense like uh
days or even weeks ahead of the
anniversary the local community and
governments
are all like discussing about like
whether
it is still legal to commemorate the
june 4 of tiananmen crackdown in hong
kong in
2021 that and many officials
have been warning the public especially
the law enforcement the police
officers they they're warning the public
that um not to take any risk of
like endangering themselves by putting
themselves in
uh under like um kind of like a possible
offense of the
uh the public ordinance and uh
also the national security law this is
the first anniversary since the
implementation of the national security
law
but of course some activist groups are
still uh
wanting to carry on the commemoration by
maybe setting up some
street booths later on in hong kong
today on the streets
and some churches are holding um like
candlelight vigil
or players gatherings within their
premises but they are all warned by the
offices that the police actually
deployed up to 7 000 offices today
just to guard every corner of hong kong
and especially the now banned kennel
division venue the victoria park
they have already sealed up that park to
really
try to stop anyone to um carry on this
kind of signature activism
uh today but uh we are expecting to see
some kind of defiance and we will see
like
how the police will going to react that
they have already
and intimidate people and threatening
like a rest
of today phoebe kong in hong kong thank
you